normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we
have this from Zero Hedge I don't think
we'll ever get to the 2024 election
Colonel Douglas McGregor retired warns
uh uh and that's this is the gist of it
uh so let's see I think oh I think
that's does he usually make bombastic
claims he's on the pbd podcast no no no
this is not he is not like uh he's not
the type of guy to just say wild things
to get a reaction this is a serious guy
this was like a highly decorated colonel
in the military he was mcmaster's boss
at one point in the military and then
just like he kind of turned against all
of the wars I believe he drew up the
plans for battle with Russia if we were
to ever go to war with the uh so they
want to they first in the zero article
break down who he is they say uh bet
David laid at how he thinks 2024 will
play out he says Nome will go around
defending Biden selling Biden's record
have him constantly attack to santis if
Biden doesn't step down have mainstream
media attack him once Jill notices the
attacks have a private meeting with
Biden sharing strategy to save face
multiple documentary showing him as a
modern FDR massive Simon and choer book
deal defend it Legacy step five choose
one of the few options to step down due
to health Jill and I prayed about it
we've we we fixed everything Trump broke
we're out step six is in order to
prevent Kamala from backstabbing let her
become the first female president for a
split second then step down divide is s
and Trump Nome becomes 47 to step eight
y yada in response to this McGregor went
dark Beginning by noting that first of
all I think it's brilliant and I think
that if we are we're living in a linear
World in other words when one event
follows the next logically you're
absolutely right but uh but I don't
think we'll ever get to the 2024
election I think things are going to
imploded in Washington before then from
there it gets more ominous now uh uh I
don't I don't know that I disagree and
one of the reasons is which we'll get
into it a little bit later is is Tik
Tock pushing the Osama bin L Osama Bin
Laden letter to America and having a
bunch of genz leftists claim that Osama
was correct again we'll talk about that
in a moment but I'm just saying the the
political divide in this country is so
psychotic right now to the point where
like we already mentioned if you're
being criminally charged in a liberal
District your best bet is to say Trump
made you do it no matter what it is
shoplifting I was watching this video
about Donald Trump and he told me to do
it please help help I'm a victim of of
the guy you hate I listen dude I'll say
still to this day and You' Tim you've
done some incredible things in in your
career but if I had to pick still to
this day what I'd say I think your
greatest moment was was still Jack dorsy
Rogan with the r because it was just
such an incredible thing it everything
lined up where like first if you
remember uh the Jack dorsy went on Rogan
and they didn't have a very
confrontational argument and it's
literally to this day the only Joe Rogan
Experience episode where I ever saw like
Joe's audience really upset with him and
and as great and this is a credit to Joe
who you know full disclosure is a friend
of mine but a credit to him is he was
like okay I hear you let's like run that
back with someone who's critical of them
but you you had the point to them and
people could accuse you of being
hyperbolic people could accuse me of
kind of the same thing um but you had
that moment to them where you were like
and I don't remember your exact words
but you were like you guys don't realize
what you're playing with here like you
don't realize the game you're playing
and you're like I'm getting a van and
like going to be bringing and like I'm
like really concerned about like you
provoking a Civil War in this country
and okay it's not like we've had a civil
war exactly since then but look we are
we know we're all flirting with it and
this is a real thing that when people
make these kind of dire warnings I
understand it's easy to go Ah that's
kind of crazy but look around at this
country man we are flirting with a lot
of very insane possibilities time travel
test go back to what was it was it 2018
or 2019 uh when I was on with with Jack
dorsy V and it might have been 2019 201
2018 it was 19 it might was it 19 yeah
yeah go back to that year and tell
people if I went back back and
everything I said was was vague
predictive like this country is headed
towards Civil War I'm get a van I'm
building a van with solar power getting
ready to bug the F out and they're
laughing like haha yeah yeah yeah right
now go back and say since then the for
the first time ever a sitting president
has been indicted in multiple
jurisdictions January 6 just January 6
alone I had uh Ryan long came here on
the show love Ryan Fant think about one
one of the first things he says when The
Show Goes live is he goes Tim you told
me there was going to be a Civil War
what happened I thought you you you were
getting me all hyped up I was really
worried when I left and then I said a
thousand Trump supporters stormed into
the capital and disrupted the Electoral
College vote count any he went oh well I
mean and even the the Riots of 2020 I
mean the fact that we had the longest
sustained riots causing billions of
dollars of property destruction that
same year so this is or the the this is
the important thing to understand is um
you know going back to something like
that debate what we're seeing with
Twitter we're seeing uh uh the the
hyperpolarization of the of of Twitter
the rules they were creating the
narratives they were swinging and the
bifurcation in American culture and
that's the point I was making like you
guys keep doing this yeah you are
creating two distinct universes and what
I could see at the time and what I can
see now is like a blur it's like when
you if anybody wears glasses you know
exactly what I mean your glasses are off
and you see a a strange shape in front
of you you can't exactly Define it but
you're like there is a person walking
towards me right now you put your
glasses on you can see it clearly if I
glass I could see the future but I'm
saying what we're witnessing right now I
as Phil leonti says what's the off-ramp
if if we're now seeing in these in these
in these January 6
cases confess and say Donald Trump made
you do it or you're done we're seeing
Enrique toio getting 20 years he wasn't
even there but more importantly since
that point we've had the Summer of Love
rights the worst rights in 50 years 30
plus deaths we've had a guy gunned down
in the street in Portland we've had
multiple autonomous zones I can't even
begin to stress how we've normalized
this go back then and say it what if I
said to Jack dorsy and V Jag got very
specifically within the next year or
year and a half there will be far-left
extremists who occupy City centers with
rifles and kill people who oppose them
they'd say you're nuts and it happened
and now we're just like oh that happened
are we not even shocked what's going on
yeah so so exactly and so the okay the
point that I'm trying to make here is
that it okay like a I don't know what
the analogy exactly would be but so
imagine um you go you know you were in a
business and you were talking to the
other like stockholders and you go I
think this business in is in real
trouble I think we're going to be out of
business next year and then next year
you're not out of business but your
stock is down 90% And they went see
you're wrong we weren't out of business
okay fine so I'm not saying yeah
technically speaking maybe you weren't
out of maybe it wasn't a civil war maybe
we weren't out of business but still at
least grant that there was like a lot
accurate to this prediction and that's
my point about by the way just tying
this back to the not being elections
maybe that's not exactly right maybe
Colonel Douglas McGregor is not word for
word right about this but there still
might be much like with your prediction
like some real insight into I'll give
you one I'll give you I'll give you the
potent the
potentiality October 2024 a single state
Secretary of State decides Donald Trump
is ineligible based on the 14th
Amendment as they've interpreted it and
so they remove his name from the ballots
immediately and we're when we're 3 weeks
out or whatever from the election so
early voting is happening immediately
you get the Trump team of all the
conservatives everyone filing emergency
notices saying we need an injunction on
this immediately and then the state says
okay we'll see you in court they go to
court by December there's a ruling yeah
guys you can't keep Trump off the ballot
oh the election's over Trump wasn't on
the ballot we've already seen in
Michigan and Minnesota they've said no
to this but the the issue would be there
look we saw this in Arizona and so I'm
not basing this off of nothing in
Arizona the wrong ballots were printed
on the wrong paper so the machines
didn't work I guarantee you I shouldn't
say that because I can't actually
guarantee you but I would tell you this
right now I will I would bet a
substantial amount of money that in 2024
we will see similar voting machine
errors on par with a misprint that
results in jurisdictions failing it may
listen if we hear about 100
jurisdictions and it totals maybe a
single percentage point that this
happened no one will accept it no matter
which side it ends up being left if it
happens to Trump if it happens to
anybody else I knew some I don't think
well the truth is that government is a
faith-based
system and that's that's especially true
for democracy the whole thing is kind of
ryant on this it's all a religion in a
way like it's all like you believe in it
we believe in look government is a
religion
in in every sense of the word right you
it has its kind of like um sacraments
and its rituals and its nobilities andow
it's sacred cows it has its blasphemy
the things you're not allowed to say
right it has all of this and also you
know much like religion um and I I say
this is someone who believes in God so
don't take this the wrong way but it is
so picture this like the religion you
don't believe in not the religion you do
believe in okay so if you're religious
every other religion not your one uh but
also it doesn't exist like government
itself doesn't exist it's an idea that's
in your head and that idea is almost
gone well right but it's that's the
point is that if it's not in your head
then it's not you know there's no there
isn't government there's buildings and
there's men with guns and who will
enforce the politicians wills and
there's titles that we made up you know
Senator Governor president but none of
that is objective reality this is an
idea that we all buy into and so when
you have something like 330 million
people in a nation and then however what
is it 140 million voters or something
like in that ballpark and they were all
recording all of their votes one day
yeah now obviously it could be a much
better system than we have here but it
requires to some degree a leap of faith
for people to just say I believe in this
system and nobody has that in the united
or very few people losing our religion I
think it's fair to say that 2012 was the
last election I'm not saying 100% it is
true I'm saying it's fair to say in that
2016 was disputed by the left as
fraudulent because Russia interfered
they even believe they flipped votes etc
etc 2020 the Trump supporter said the
same thing of the Democrats I don't care
who you think is right or wrong you're
allowed to think you're right you're
allowed to think other people are wrong
the point is we have now had two
elections where both sides have accused
each other of very dramatic
serious yes and the point is that that
it's almost like if you believe it then
you're right cuz the point I'm making
about saying it's like a religion again
I I really just to be clear I'm not
trying to knock the idea of religion I'm
saying like some of the things that I
think are the most beautiful ideas in
institutions in the world I think
marriage is amongst the most beautiful
institutions in the world but in a
marriage if either the husband or the
wife doesn't believe in it anymore then
they're right right there there is no
there is no objective thing there it's
like if you don't believe it it like
then you're you're right then you're not
in this anymore it almost requires both
of you to believe in this thing that
it's
real but
do you can get into how you trap your
wife in the basement after this but I'm
just saying I'm saying my wife is free
to leave anytime she wants to and she
doesn't want to
leave she's Catholic though right so but
you're not baptized yeah well it's a
different situation but my point is but
you don't believe in the concept of like
sacramental marriage or that you're like
actually Bound in a way where you can't
leave I'm not saying that you're not I'm
saying you can believe that you're bound
in that way and I do believe that I yes
I believe that I've made a commitment to
my wife that I said in front of our
families and in front of God and that I
will till death do us part uh and yes I
believe that but if I stop believing
that it doesn't exist anymore that's my
point it's it requires the belief in
that otherwise it's over and so in a
sense even though it is completely
ridiculous for the the left half of
America to say that Vladimir Putin
overthrew the government in 2016 when he
installed Trump them believing that in
itself changes the whole dynamics of
politics and the same thing for Trump
supporters who believe the election was
stolen in 2020 now I'm not saying it
wasn't or it was I'm just saying once
you believe that we're not playing the
same game anymore you you're but you're
putting on like the lens of what you
think is right and wrong I'm saying
forget what you think is right or wrong
I'm saying if your wife stops believing
that she has she's going to act as if
she's not married you're in a different
game you're in a different game now
certainly different situation and so
that's what we're dealing with in
America today yeah no my point is simply
to say that I I agree with some of what
you're saying and I think ultimately we
would just disagree on like the moral
questions of how you're sort of
formulating the analogy the way I
understand it is I believe obviously in
the the tress of my faith I also believe
there are such things as false religions
I think anytime you have a false idol
you have a false religion and government
has become an idol for many people
especially people in government they
really do see themselves as the highest
moral Authority even fouchi is saying
something like I am the science I mean
that is a mockery of Christ I am the way
I am the truth I am the life fouchi is
saying he is truth itself and they also
say that science is the way and the life
they have this insane kind of scientist
system of thought built up where anyone
who calls themselves an expert is now
entitled to tell you exactly how how to
live your life they have the fullness of
the truth so I I totally agree that
there are parallels here with with um
false religions rothbart actually talked
about this in anatomy of the state that
once faith in the state declines they
would replace it with a technocracy or s
scientism it's exactly what we've seen
we that they're basically evolving
naturally but I I want to point I want
to go back to a point from a minute ago
when you were talking about uh you know
sitting down with Jack dorsy on on Rogan
the whole reason that oh first off you
didn't know at the time but BEC thanks
to Elon musk's acquisition and the
Twitter leagues we now know that much of
those policies in the terms of service
modification as well as the moderation
policy shifts were being dictated by a
multitude of three-letter agencies now
let's back up a little bit further the
whole reason that that they felt
genuinely righteous in in modifying
these things even if you discount the
FBI interference and everything else was
because they felt genuinely that Donald
Trump had had the election stolen
because of Russian interference that was
also the state that had planted those
seeds all fictitious Hillary Clinton the
steel dossier all AE so you have this
entire censorship apparatus that is
being ruled out and you have useful
idiots that are actually propagating it
based off of deception that is all a CIA
plan from the get-go now let's just to
just to add to what you said they are
they genuinely believe Trump stole the
election he's a he's a Putin asset so he
must be stopped but that narrative
itself was created by them and this is
why I have long described Twitter as
Jack dorsy hooking his own sewer system
into his own mouth dorsy created Twitter
with a team and everybody's sharing
ideas crackpot psychotic refu is
splattered all over the place on Twitter
and Jack dorsy decides I'm going to take
that funnel and shove it down my throat
and starts consuming it he then adopts
the ideology of chaos listen this is the
important thing the the uh Tik Tock
story uh uh about j z believing Bin
Laden was correct because they read his
letter proves my point there's no way
they actually read his letter if they
did it's all anti-lgbt they didn't
actually read it they're simply saying
they agree with it because they're
seeing other people say it Jack dorsy
saw the same Trends decided to abide by
them without kn what he was talking
about and that's what the left is and he
built rules around it which helped
propagate the very cult all right before
we get into the the Osama Bin Laden
letter if I just one thing on on that
like and I don't completely disagree
with you but there is kind of like
another element into this which is that
look if you look at the state of social
media from uh pre
2016 it was just a different world and
I'm not saying that nobody ever got like
banned or kicked off there were very
rare instances where people would go
really really far like where people
would actually be like advocating like
you know Nazism and stuff like that
where they would get banned but it was
very rare I mean I remember back in the
days and of the Wild Wild West and I say
that in the best possible sense of the
term as a Libertarian love the Wild Wild
West uh but that it was a you could kind
of say whatever you wanted to without
any fear that like oh I better watch
myself or I bet I'm and of course was
because all of the incentives lined up
for social media companies to not want
to kick people off because there was
real competition still well look the
whole thing is they want you to be on
their site they don't want to kick you
off but so so let me give you the the
quick finish your thought so I can well
so my point is that the rise of Donald
Trump who really tweeted his way to the
presidency and tweeted his way to the
presidency when the entire establishment
said this guy is not allowed to win and
ended up winning and use Twitter to
drive the entire news cycle through the
entire uh uh uh election once he won the
the all of the powerful people in
government in the media class they
couldn't simply accept that oh he had a
message that resonated with the people
even though we told you there was no way
this message would resonate with the
people and we couldn't accept that
Hillary Clinton turns out to just be a
horrifically corrupt unlikable awful
human being and but this was I'm just
saying this actually happened that they
hauled all all of the heads of uh the
big social media the big tech companies
in front of Congress and explicitly in
front of everybody threatened them with
violence you know they threatened them
with we will regulate your the reason
Trump won is because of disinformation
and Russian interference and you better
do something about that or else ofat
that was that was a factor in what
happened a maor fact give you the quick
rundown um of what social media started
as social media website post what you
want to post people did
eventually too many people are posting
Facebook says people their feeds are
cluttered up reverse chronological isn't
working we need them to stay on the
website algorithms were were created
algorithms will deliver to you content
we think you like better many of them
failed the early algorithms of YouTube
were if it gets more clicks show it more
what happened every thumbnail became
women in bikinis I'm dead serious right
what ends up happening then is a bunch
of companies start emerging Huffington
Post one of the first all of a sudden
they're getting massive traffic
everyone's clicking their articles they
can read the news now not through a
newspaper and comment on these stories
what ends up happening through the
algorithms Facebook says share the links
that get the most clicks what happens
then what gets the most clicks police
brutality videos things that in in uh
make people angry get the most clicks
overnight in the early 2010s we end up
seeing my favorite example is mike.com
do you guys know that started as a Ron
Paul Pro Ron Paul website yeah you told
me about it mike.com started as
libertarian Pro Ron Paul
and with a component of anti- police
brutality because Libertarians were very
into this eventually however Mike
becomes social justice why it was
getting more clicks to go beyond police
brutality this whole machine's always
been in play so we can say pre- 2016 it
was a different story no no no no you
were just and you were walking into the
building you just didn't see the bowels
deep so I don't I I don't deny that and
I think there is part of this that just
was an organic force of like how can we
get more clicks and more clicks and more
clicks but I am saying that like there
there was a government intervention and
obviously we know from all of like the
Twitter files and all of that stuff now
that there was massive like government
intervention that certainly put their
thumb on this scale and said and
particularly I'm not just saying about
the clickbait stuff I'm more talking
about like the tech censorship stuff
where they really did crack down on
these companies and insist that you like
censor dissenting voices and often times
well let me just say and often times it
was dissenting voices who were getting
tons of clips and what you need to
understand is the people working for the
Intel agencies are not like it's a
30-year-old guy in 20 in 2005 who is now
a 40-year-old guy in 2015 who went whoa
we better censor this it is in 2015 them
hiring a new 30-year-old who's been
indoctrinated for 10 years by the refu
machine a 10-year-old a kid born in 2000
gets on the internet gets on Facebook
for the first time in 2010 and what does
he see on Facebook literally nothing but
police brutality videos the the police
brutality was was so ubiquitous on
Facebook that one of there was a website
dedicated to nothing but police
brutality videos in the top 500 Global
websites making millions of dollars
you're 10 years old you get on Facebook
and it's all you see yeah for the next
four or five years and your formative
years the only thing you see guess what
they're BLM activists now now you have
critical race theorists and marxists now
imagine this imagine you're already 10
years old in in 2000 and you're just
starting to get on the internet by the
time you're 15 you're being inundated
with this stuff 10 years later to 25
you're now working in these Intel
agencies you're you're out of college
you're interning this is what we saw
with budlight I predicted this I said
I'm willing to bet it's going to turn
out I was talking to Vi about this it's
a young Millennial marketing person who
is just brought on and is Ros risen in
the ranks and is now trying to push
their crackpot garbage into the machine
what did it turn out to be exactly that
a millennial woman who said let's do
wokeness and then burn the company to
the ground cuz we don't want these frat
boy customers that buy you know millions
of cans of our every year why why are we
seeing 16-year-olds in San Francisco
marching through the hallways chanting
from The River To The Sea do you
genuinely think these kids know anything
about Israel Palestine no they've been
indoctrinated by their by their schools
let's let's get let's let's go to it
baby not just their SCH we got we got
one point about that after we jump to
the next story point we can make well I
just want to say you mentioned their
brainwashed by their schools that's
that's certainly true in part um I I had
the privilege of speaking to Dr George
bar on my podcast and he's done research
on what to form the beliefs of the youth
in America and what he found is that
like without a close second media is
basically what shapes their opinions
when you look at schools you look at
parents you look at churches it's far
far above all of those things is Media
what they're consuming on television
basically or on social media thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at
timcast.net
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time